y
[Música]
en el día 44 de guerra en ucrania el
impacto de un misil en la localidad de
grama torch en la pro rusa región de
donges dejó al menos 50 muertos entre
ellos 5 menores y unos 100 heridos el
misil impactó sobre la estación de tren
de la ciudad donde miles de personas
esperaban a ser evacuadas
la presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen y el jefe de la
diplomacia de la unión europea se
aburren estuvieron en lucha allí
visitaron una fosa común tras lo que
font der leyen aseguró haber visto el
rostro cruel del ejército ruso
posteriormente se reunieron con
volodymyr del esquí en kiev y
prometieron más apoyo
y este domingo 10 de abril francia vota
en sus elecciones presidenciales más de
48 millones de franceses están llamados
a las urnas para elegir entre 12
candidatos en la primera vuelta si nadie
consigue más del 50% de los votos habrá
un balotaje el 24 de abril
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos esta
emisión en ucrania en donde se cuentan
al menos 50 muertos entre ellos cinco
menores y unos cien heridos en la
localidad de crumb a torch en la profusa
región de donges un misil impactó sobre
una estación de tren donde cientos de
personas en su mayoría mujeres y niños
esperaban para huir de la ciudad ante
las amenazas de un incremento de la
ofensiva rusa marina sardiña tiene los
detalles
un infierno en la tierra así describen
los supervivientes el ataque sobre la
estación de tren de cta matos la región
de doñetsk
sinceramente pensé que iba a morir lo
peor es que si esto ocurriera todos los
días en nuestra ciudad sería aterrador
había muchas mujeres y niños
unas 4.000 personas en su mayoría
mujeres y niños esperaban ser evacuadas
ante las amenazas de una gran ofensiva
de moscú cuando un misil acabó con sus
vidas naciones unidas calificó el ataque
de completamente inaceptable
oh sí
todos los principales estados del mundo
han condenado ya el ataque de rusia 14
esperamos una respuesta firme y global a
este crimen de guerra al igual que las
masacres de lucha al igual que muchos
otros crímenes de guerra rusos el ataque
con misiles sobre crematorio debe ser
una de las acusaciones en el tribunal lo
que seguramente ocurrirá como estas en
la tribuna o jackie o podio es como jim
muntz mientras tanto en bolo dianca
continúan las tareas de búsqueda y
rescate entre las ruinas ya se han
recuperado más de 25 cuerpos después de
que las fuerzas rusas golpearan barrios
residenciales
mis hijos yacían bajo los escombros
acaban de sacar a mis hijos de debajo de
los escombros
durante 36 días la gente permaneció bajo
los escombros y los rusos dispararon
impidieron que sacaran a la gente
en el noroeste del país los residentes
de jarque también limpian los escombros
muchos civiles alegan que fueron
atacados con proyectiles y cohetes rusos
en los últimos días los funcionarios
regionales han instado a los civiles
abandonar sus hogares
hubo una explosión las ventanas
comenzaron a temblar corrimos al baño y
escuchamos una explosión extremadamente
fuerte por nuestro sur cuando se cumplen
44 días de guerra en ucrania las fuerzas
del kremlin continúan golpeando con
dureza a la indefensa población civil lo
que las autoridades ucranianas califican
como crímenes de lesa humanidad la
presidenta de la comisión europea aula
font der leyen y el jefe de la
diplomacia europea josep borrel se
reunieron el viernes en kiev con el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
más temprano en el mismo día visitaron
butch a la ciudad que se convirtió en un
símbolo de las atrocidades de la guerra
en ucrania los representantes del bloque
prometieron más ayuda y acelerar el
ingreso del país a la unión europea
ampliamos en el siguiente informe
una visita en solidaridad con los
habitantes de mucha una ciudad que
simboliza las atrocidades de la guerra
bajo la mirada de los líderes europeos
ursula von der leyen anillos de aboga el
decenas de cuerpos de civiles
encontrados en fosas comunes
lo impensable ha ocurrido aquí
hemos visto la cara cruel del ejército
de putin sólo what es morning nuestro
equipo pucha el mundo entero está de
luto con el pueblo de wood chance
que es el que defiende la frontera de
europa la humanidad y la democracia
human edge y fijan de limousin
la jornada continuó en kiev donde se
reunieron con el presidente evo los
dineros del en skins en la agenda
figuraba la quinta serie de sanciones
adoptadas este viernes que incluye un
embargo del carbón ruso a partir de
agosto
o supuestos a piatti personalmente
agradezco el quinto paquete de sanciones
pero creo que no es suficiente ellos nos
quitaron mucho nos quitaron territorios
y personas podremos recuperar
territorios y no podremos recuperar
personas y habrá una enorme injusta
responsabilidad por ello estoy seguro de
ello por eso pido ayuda en forma de
sanciones hay que endurecer las de lo
contrario rusia no querrá escuchar a
nada ni a nadie mójate soy más al tema
estamos a sus lados este es el mensaje
que úrsula von der leyen da recalcó
entregó bajo los límites del skin
cuestionario que debía rellenar en el
marco del procedimiento de adhesión a la
unión europea
la presidenta de la comisión espera que
la solicitud de ucrania pueda
presentarse al concejo este mismo verano
y en francia 12 candidatos se
enfrentarán el domingo 10 de abril en la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales quién puede votar todos
son elegibles como candidatos electos
qué pasa en una hipotética segunda ronda
les explicamos el sistema electoral
francés en el siguiente informe
los votantes franceses eligen
directamente a su presidente por
sufragio universal el voto es abierto
para todos los ciudadanos franceses
mayores de 18 años siempre que no estén
legalmente inhabilitados para votar y
estén inscritos en la lista electoral
las mismas reglas se aplican a los
candidatos quienes también deben mostrar
un sentido de dignidad moral un término
vago sin una definición legal clara y
reunir 500 firmas de apoyo de
representantes electos
cualquiera que cumpla con estos
criterios es elegible para participar en
la primera ronda si nadie gana con una
mayoría absoluta más del 50 por ciento
de los votos los candidatos con mayor
puntuación se enfrentan en una segunda
vuelta aquí es donde entra a jugar el
voto estratégico en la segunda ronda
muchos votantes se elegirán a un
candidato que inicialmente no apoyaron
para bloquear a otro contendiente esto
sucedió por primera vez en 2002 cuando
el ultraderechista jean-marie le pen
llegó inesperadamente a la segunda ronda
su oponente el titular de entonces
jacques chirac obtuvo más del 82% de los
votos el mayor margen en la historia del
país les recordamos que este domingo 10
de abril tendremos un especial sobre la
primera vuelta de las presidenciales
francesas más de 48 millones de
franceses están llamados a las urnas
podrán conectarse con nosotros a partir
del mediodía hora de bogotá quito y lima
en estados unidos la próxima jueza de la
corte suprema estadounidense que está
librando jackson celebró su confirmación
por parte del senado en un acto con el
presidente joe biden y la vicepresidenta
kamala harris en la casa blanca la
jurista se comprometió a que una vez que
asuma el cargo realizará su trabajo con
independencia
previamente no reportó al respecto
nuestro corresponsal en washington
cristóbal basket
acompañada de su familia amigos cercanos
congresistas y gabinete del gobierno que
tal y brawn jackson cerebro desde la
casa blanca la confirmación a la corte
suprema de justicia tras un proceso de
42 días de debate en el senado de eeuu
53 senadores al final votaron a favor de
ella y 47 en contra logrando la mayoría
simple para convertirse así en la cuarta
mujer en la máxima institución judicial
de eeuu la primera afroamericana en la
historia y la más joven del grupo de
nueve magistrados que conforman la corte
y empezará entonces sus funciones en
octubre en un emotivo discurso dijo que
ella ha trabajado duro para llegar a
este punto de su carrera y que ha
logrado mucho más de que lo de lo que
sus abuelos imaginaron pero aclaró
varias veces que nadie hace esto por su
propia cuenta que su camino había sido
despejado para que ella pudiera estar a
la altura de esta ocasión finalmente y
entre aplausos y lágrimas de los
asistentes la juez braun jackson dijo
que ella es hoy el sueño y la esperanza
del esclavo
en brasil el ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva anunció a la alianza
política con su histórico rival el
liberal geraldo alckim de cara a las
elecciones de octubre el acuerdo desata
los recelos del ala más izquierdista del
partido de los trabajadores pero ahonda
en la imagen de un lula conciliador que
pese a todo aún no ha oficializado su
candidatura
y en otras noticias de américa latina'
la corte internacional de derechos
humanos ordenó a perú abstenerse de
liberar al expresidente alberto fujimori
condenado por crímenes de lesa humanidad
e indultado el 17 de marzo por el
tribunal constitucional peruano por
razones humanitarias la corte se ampara
en el derecho a justicia de las víctimas
para fallar en contra del constitucional
peruano
[Música]
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan conectados a france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]